ever wonder what a live-action Troy
McClure movie would have looked like how
about Mrs Doubtfire too keep your eyes
on the screen to learn about these cool
projects and others that nearly got the
green light
Phil Hartman had a superpower he could
make anything funny take for instance
Troy McClure his iconic role in The
Simpsons you might remember this
character from The Planet of the Apes
musical he starred in the clip shows he
hosted or The infomercials he attached
his name to hi I'm Troy McClure you may
remember me from such nature films as
earwig's ew and Man vs nature the road
to Victory do any of those sound
hilarious in concept not so much are
they gut bustingly funny when depicted
by Phil Hartman absolutely before
Hartman was murdered he was part of
early talks for a live-action Troy
McClure film most accounts indicate that
Hartman himself pushed the idea in that
many Simpsons staff writers were on
board including Matt Groening tragically
Hartman was killed by his wife before
any of this could take place graining
had flirted with the idea of a
live-action Simpson spin-off before in
1994 he and Michael Whitehorn completed
a pilot script for a show that focused
on Krusty the Clown it never got off the
ground but thankfully this was not due
to anyone's death
following his trial for child
molestation in 2005 Michael Jackson
spent the next few years away from the
spotlight he slowly rehabilitated His
Image but also desperately needed money
as such in March of 2009 he announced
this is it a year-long residency at the
O2 Arena in London starting that July
when I say this is it it really means
this is it less than a month before the
first show however Jackson died of acute
propofol and benzodiazepine intoxication
at the age of 50. AEG live who promoted
the concert decided to make some money
off of the event anyway they put
together a documentary concert film
titled Michael Jackson's This Is It
which was released theatrically in
October 2009 while some fans were
dismayed by what they saw as Shameless
profiteering they were massively
outnumbered by those who saw the film
which made 261 million dollars worldwide
the documentary was surprisingly low-key
limited by the fact that its footage is
entirely from rehearsals in the wake of
Jackson's shocking death however that
was more than enough to make it into a
hit
Sam Kinison was killed near the peak of
his popularity by a drunk driver this
sudden and tragic loss sent shock waves
through the comedy world he left behind
a series of classic stand-up albums TV
guest spots and music video appearances
he also had several projects lined up
that were ultimately canceled including
one with Arnold Schwarzenegger Bill
kinnison Sam's brother and business
manager revealed in 2009 that the
comedian had signed a deal with new line
Cinema for three movies shortly before
his death one would have been a
straightforward concert film one would
have been a movie with Rick Moranis and
one would have been a truly star-studded
Affair of this last film Bill kinnison
shared it was going to be Schwarzenegger
Beverly D'Angelo Christina Applegate and
Corey Feldman the movie was about Sam as
a convict and it's an adopt a convict
thing he comes and lives with you to
help him straighten out his life and all
that alas it was not to be the movie was
shelved following kennison's death
the death of Robin Williams shocked the
world the comic giant left behind a
stunning Legacy as well as four in
production films that were eventually
released there was however one project
that went unfinished the sequel to Mrs
Doubtfire
attempts at a Mrs Doubtfire sequel date
back to at least 2001. both Robin
Williams and Chris Columbus repeatedly
turned down scripts they found
uninspiring as Williams said Mrs
Doubtfire being unmasked in the original
movie made a Repeat Performance
difficult but a sequel was finally
announced in April of 2014. Williams was
set to Star Columbus was signed on to
direct an elf screenwriter David
berenbaum would script it of course
Williams 2014 death put an end to the
movie
Training Day a TV sequel to the 2001
Denzel Washington film of the same name
was set to become a headlining CBS
series
Bill Paxton starred as detective Frank
Roark alongside Justin Cornwell as
officer Kyle Craig just a few weeks
after the series premiere however Paxton
died of a stroke following open heart
surgery he was 61. Paxton had shot all
13 episodes of training day's first
season prior to his death allowing it to
air as planned the show saw a small
raiding Spike after he died but reviews
weren't spectacular and its audience
dwindled as the weeks wore on between
low ratings lackluster reviews and the
death of the show's biggest star CBS
chose not to recast the Rourke role and
pulled the plug after one season
Hollywood spent much of the 1980s and
the 1990s trying to bring Mordecai
richler's novel The incomparable attack
to the Silver Screen a fish out of water
story about a Canadian Inuit adapting to
life in the big city the screenplay
simply titled a tuck went through many
stars so many in fact that it is now
believed to be cursed John Belushi was
the first star attached to the role and
was by some accounts whose screenwriter
Tom Carroll had in mind when writing the
script Belushi's death in 1982 put an
end to that years later producers
reached out to John Candy who was
interested but died while still studying
the script overtures were made to Chris
Farley though he too died shortly after
expressing interest to this day the film
has never been made while his death
didn't cancel the project it is also
worth noting that Sam Kinison was cast
in 1988 and actually shot a scene he
later took issue with the script and
left resulting in a breach of contract
lawsuit he died young as well whether or
not the curse claimed him is up to you
River Phoenix died in the middle of
shooting the American Dutch Thriller
dark blood leaving the project canceled
and unfinished that might have been the
end of it for most films but director
George slizer had other plans in 2011 18
years after Phoenix's 1993 death slizer
revealed that he still had the dark
blood footage worried that his work
would be destroyed splizer swiped the
negative from the insurance company that
was threatening to destroy it to avoid
storage costs from there he re-edited
the footage into something approaching a
finished film slicer announced that he
had stayed in touch with the Phoenix
family and that he planned to ask
Joaquin Phoenix if he'd be willing to
redub some of River's lines in response
the entire Phoenix family made their
disinterest explicitly clear they wanted
no part of this somehow slicer still did
it in dark blood premiered at the 2012
Netherlands Film Festival
Chris Farley's public Persona as Brash
and Goofy was at odds with his true self
a gentleman self-conscious about his
size and unhappy with being Typecast not
long before he died he was hard at work
on a biopic about silent movie star
Roscoe Fatty Arbuckle the project had
promise and could have expanded his
career Beyond clowning but it wasn't
completed before he died Arbuckle was
one of the first True Hollywood stars he
was a gifted physical comedian and
remarkably agile for his size but he was
privately insecure and resentful of his
girth Arbuckle is best remembered today
for being accused of the rape and murder
of silent film star Virginia repay he
was exonerated after three trials so
much so that the jury of the last trial
apologized to him regardless his career
was effectively over Farley knew this
role could change his career his
obsession with the movie endured through
the haze of his addictions to the point
that some colleagues believed it to be
an unhealthy fixation ultimately he
never got clean and died of a drug
overdose in 1997.
John Kennedy tools A Confederacy of
Dunces is an iconic work of American
literature as such attempts to adapt it
to the screen are many yet none of them
have come to fruition John Belushi was
the first actor cast in the lead role of
Ignatius J Reilly a day or two before he
was supposed to finalize his involvement
he died of a drug overdose years later
another attempt at adapting Dunces was
made John Candy was courted for the lead
role until he too passed away ditto
Chris Farley who is considered for the
role of Ignatius until his 1997 death
brought talks to an abrupt end
Natalie Wood's enigmatic death by
Drowning is a landmark Hollywood tragedy
she didn't just leave behind an enduring
mystery she also left behind at least
two projects that went unfinished a few
weeks after she died actor Timothy
Hutton said that he and wood had
purchased the film rights to Barbara
warsba's book country of the Heart the
book tells the story of a Teenage writer
Who falls in love with a famous novelist
dying of cancer her death stopped the
project before it could ever start the
novel has since faded Into Obscurity
wood was also a few months out for
making her stage debut she was working
on Anastasia a play about the tragic
Russian princess set to debut at the
Amazon theater in Los Angeles Tony
winner Arvin Brown was attached to
direct with rehearsals to start in
January 1982 and opening night scheduled
for the following February development
of the show ended upon her death